of course this is your mum girl that's
the worst what did you feel guilty for
oh just that I wasn't with her you know
and I wanted to be with her and you know
ultimately I know why I'm working and I
really enjoy work and it's a funny stage
to be in and I I was really lucky in my
old business I was really well supported
with that conversation welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host Tisha
mizzouz on this week's episode I was
joined by Charlotte flood we finally had
someone from Australia back on the Pod
it's been a while Charlotte you've been
you know in recruitment for over 10
years and you've really you know
consistently built a network and served
the pr Communications industry you're
building your family unit whilst
building your career so you're the
mother of two so in this conversation we
speak about her journey in transitioning
to selling retained Solutions and how
she got much better at pitching and
successfully selling that solution as
well as something that's really
important to Charlotte and that is
building a family that she's proud of
whilst building her career in
recruitment so we definitely talk about
prioritization time management
productivity and a whole lot more what
you believe are the common
characteristics and traits current top
performers in today's market have in
common yeah um I guess for me it's all
about
enjoy this week's episode
Charlotte welcome to the podcast
hello
thank you so much for joining me
you're welcome it's all good from Sunny
Sydney yeah there we go I haven't uh
obviously sent to Ryan I haven't had you
know someone from you know your part of
the world for a little while
um a lot of people that do listen to the
podcast
are based in Australia so I'm really
excited for this conversation I guess
what I always like to do for people
listening is just give them all some
immediate context on
who you are the journey that you're on
and if I miss anything in terms of like
you know the key highlights please
please uh correct me but Charlotte
you've been you know in recruitment for
over 10 years and you've really you know
consistently built a network and served
the the pr Communications industry
I think for most of the time you've been
doing permanent recruitment but there's
been elements where you've done some
contract but predominance being perm I
know you're you know a proud mother who
you know you're building your family
unit whilst building your career so
you're the mother of two
um and that's all happened whilst you've
built your recruitment career
and
obviously over the last 12 months just
over 12 months you joined a business
called creative natives
after working for your previous business
for nearly 10 years
and
um obviously we can't say exactly
because I don't know if it's at the end
of the year but I'm pretty sure you're
on track to have your best year yet
yeah that's right hopefully hope so
anyway but yeah looking like it yeah
um so amazing so look we're always like
to start Charlotte is I'd love to sort
of hear your perspective on what you
believe are the common characteristics
and traits that you know current top
performers in today's market have in
common
yeah um I guess for me it's all about
you know being really values LED and
true to yourself authentic and really
giving a damn about what you're doing
and why you're doing it
um I think sometimes can be missed in
recruitment is that you know you might
see your job but a candidate and want to
place them and then you kind of move on
and you don't realize the actual impact
you're having on someone's whole life
you know you've got their career in your
hands you know which then impacts their
day-to-day life their home life their
families you know their ongoing future
so I think you know and then you know in
turn the kind of mental health aspect as
well so I think taking a step back
sometimes as a recruiter and really
focusing on that and understanding that
and having that level of emotional
intelligence is really really important
um obviously for me you know to be a
really good recruiter I think you need
to be really good at like prioritizing
and just kind of really setting you know
setting things out for the day but also
being compassionate and honest and
managed expectations around that as well
and also being curious you know I think
asking questions is really imperative
um organized really driven and then also
you know
we I am competitive I'm not competitive
against you know my team or you know
anything like that or against
individuals but I think inwardly
competitive I don't think there are any
recruiters out there who you know good
recruiters that have done really well
that can say that they're not
competitive I think that's just
something that's innate in a in a
recruiter and a good recruiter anyway
and then I think you know certainly
something that I've experienced is to
have like you know you you do grow a bit
of a thick skin you know it's important
not to take yourself too seriously you
know you are going to experience
knockbacks in days where it just all
goes to and you know you've just
got to be able to pick yourself up and
dust yourself off and get on with it and
yeah it's it's all about that for me
yeah loads there are prioritization
mindset resilience we're definitely
gonna go into the prioritization piece
because I find it really interesting
when we prepare for this I guess let's
just get straight into it what I was
just really Keen
to find out uh from you and understand
is you've been doing your market for a
long time
right yeah so I guess where I just
wanted to to start was I'd love to get
your perspective on how has Charlotte
made sure that she doesn't get
complacent
um because I really feel like you know
when you've done a certain industry for
a long time you've been doing it for
well over a decade you work for one
business for nearly 10 years so you know
complacency can creep in you have your
clients they give you the great jobs you
have the people that you speak to
um not saying that you know it's still
not hard but complacency can definitely
creep in so how have you
you mentioned competitiveness there but
how have you continued over the the
years to really make sure that you know
you continue to keep trying to improve
keep trying to get better and it'll get
complacent because you've done the same
market for so long yeah that's a really
good question I think the market itself
like the pr and comms Market is really
varied so for me it's it's been quite
difficult to ever feel complacent in it
because I wear so many hats on so many
different days you know like I could be
in speaking to
um you know the MD of a financial PR
agency and then equally going the other
end of the spectrum and going in to see
a fashion PR agency so I think it really
keeps me on my toes and I I find it
really interesting and I have to learn
new things every single day and I do
keep on top of you know what's happening
what my clients are doing you know their
award-winning campaigns and things like
that I do I do understand where you're
coming from though and I think since
making the move to creative natives I
think there's like you know any
complacency that I may have been feeling
along the way you know the back end of
my my last role has completely vanished
you know I think it's it's the fresh
perspective we do things very
differently
um we've got a lot a lot of great tools
here the teams really engaged and yeah I
don't I've never really thought about
getting complacent in in the market that
I'm in and I've never really felt that
that way because I do feel like I I am
challenged and we do challenge ourselves
on a day-to-day basis and you know it's
it's a very busy desk I don't think
there's been much time for complacency
to be honest
no I love it okay cool so would you mind
just sharing because I think this would
be helpful for people
um before we go into the the sort of
granular details here
I think currently if I'm wrong but
obviously in the last 12 months not
entirely for the um whole year but over
the last seven or eight months have you
been on a journey where you've been
working a lot more like a retained basis
with your clients and customers
is that fair yeah that's right that's
right yeah I'd say we brought in we're
working in much more of a retained model
for the last yeah nine to ten months now
which is which has been great okay um
sorry I was gonna say yeah we'll
definitely get into that but I just
wanted to make sure that I understood
that and um clarified that
um I guess like why don't we one of the
things that when we prepared for this
that I found really interesting
just to sort of just go really Grand in
here really really quickly was
um you shared with me how like right now
you you work three and a half days or
four days
I work three and a half days yeah three
and a half days
we'll try to have our our best year yeah
which is what around 700 something right
yeah yeah around that I should I should
expect hopefully and obviously the best
year before that I think you said was
just under 600.
yeah probably around five five fifty
Mark yeah
so
I guess what um what I just wanted to
you know get your perspective on was
what do you think because you told me
that you got really good at just
basically saying like no prioritizing
being like really on it because you know
Charlotte has to do this the school run
at whatever time you have to you know
you have to leave the office you have
you know really protected time with your
family on Fridays so I guess I just
wanted to start the conversation of if
you were to look at like your earlier
career or as you were you know climbing
uh the ranks and building
um your brand and Market what do you
think in hindsight Charlotte
probably
um said yes to or found yourself
um working on and the way that you're
working that now you probably wouldn't
so like what things now would you say no
to that maybe you know as you're earlier
on you'd say yes to and you would do
that maybe yeah it resulted in you not
being as efficient not being as like you
know proper on it because of your time
and then yeah we'll go into like how you
do it now but I just thought I'd start
there because a lot of people listen to
this you know building their career
and sometimes you have to you know go on
a bit of a contingent boost chase you
have to learn things the hard way but
looking back what do you think you
probably said yeah yes to and allowed
compared to what you wouldn't allow now
if you get what I mean yeah absolutely I
I think I probably you know fell into
the Trap I'm a bit of a people pleaser
like I like to help people so I probably
would have fallen into the trap for sure
of basically just trying to help any
single candidate that came across my
desk because I thought you know what I
mean I just you know they might not have
even been relevant for my space and and
just you know and trying to engage with
them on sem level whether that be a
quick phone call or an email or whatever
that may be and then equally you know
which which isn't it's just not time
efficient like you just can't do that
and it's also not managing their
expectations either you know if if I
can't help somebody now I have like
because I'm so probably time portrait
certain extent I have like
um like canned responses in my emails so
I do respond to everyone that comes
through to me if um for a role or
whatever that may be but but I can point
them in the right direction or I'll give
them like an immediate response so that
I feel like I can park that and move on
to like important tasks and equally I
would have definitely picked up rubbish
briefs because she's sort of been like
oh yeah I'll work that that's absolutely
fine you know when you look back and you
think oh my goodness what what should I
do that for there was no information
there and you know no solid brief didn't
agree with the values of the business or
anything like that you know and how am I
ever going to get anyone to work there
and then that's detrimental to everyone
involved so yeah for sure
so talking about rubbish briefs because
I think we can all learn from that like
what what did rubbish briefs look like
was it you was just an order taken
you're like yep yep no problem yep
salaries like nowhere near what it
should be but yeah no problem could do
that like what what did a rubbish brief
look like oh don't get me wrong I still
get the old one-line emails you know
too but yeah I guess yeah just you know
oh I'm looking for an account manager
um for my business and like what are you
meant to do with that that's no
information whatsoever and then also
equally if you do get them on the phone
and they're not willing to share any
information with you you know on on you
know what what's expected in the role
the background of the talent whether
they you know do whether they think
outside the box whether they've got an
EVP in place like you want to be asking
those kind of questions you know and you
want responses to that because my market
is so Talent tight that if I get a great
talent I can you know I can phone a
number of agencies who will then want to
interview them and if I get a rubbish
break there's just nothing I can do with
that like it just there has to be depth
to my brief so yeah
do you think is there any advice that
you could share for someone that you
know is in the first couple of years of
their uh career and you know it can be
hard sometimes to really lean into that
being a consultant and not being an
order taker because you know you
continue to build your confidence you
continue to build your track record so
sometimes you can just feel really
grateful that they're giving you that
job or you've got that opportunity but
maybe deep down you're like this is
going to be really difficult but how do
I sort of advise them that you know this
isn't this isn't realistic this is going
to be really difficult and I think
sometimes as you get more and more
experience I become you're like more
comfortable to do that is it anything
that you can share that maybe you would
have you know given yourself advice on
to help you have less pull briefs or
like would you approach it a bit
differently anything to share there
yeah I would say like you know if if a
client's gonna engage with you you then
want to book in like a proper time stop
with them so you want to have a video
call or in person meet I think that's
imperative and then feel free like I
still will sometimes have like mini
scripts that you know that of certain
questions that I want to ask a client
like I think it's really important
especially when you're starting off to
almost have that script and just be like
these are the questions I'm going to ask
and you know and put some curveballs in
there as well and if the client isn't
able to ask all them then I would
question why again and then also I add
feedback to your client and say you know
it's brilliant to take this brief really
appreciate the business but you know I'm
going to struggle X Y and Z in these
kind of areas the Market's really
competitive it would be great to go a
bit more in depth you know have a proper
JD have your EVP you know I want can you
can you look at like you know part-time
work increase flexibility for this like
what's going to sell you what's your
culture like why do you like working
there because you know my candidate's
got a multitude of offers you know sorry
you know like um areas that they can go
into and why would they choose you above
you know your competition and I think
also just from from that part as well
like don't be afraid to phone your
clients and keep in contact with them
like through the resourcing part of it
as well and give them a call or drop
them an email saying where you know
where you might be finding it
problematic and give them feedback on
what you know what candidates are saying
about the brief in the market as well so
I think that's really important it's
hard like I get it you know when you're
starting off on recruitment it does take
a lot to be able to have those
conversations but I think it's really
important you know for for you moving
forward to be able to try to do that
no I think that that's really helpful
and I'm sort of the sort of thing I was
hoping you'd share I guess I'd be it'd
be rude not to ask obviously I don't
want to know all the questions on the
script but what would be Charlotte's
non-negotiables so like if you know
we're starting this like the absolute
must questions you have to ask if you
was helping someone in your team now
these are the non-negotiables that you
have to ask for you that you think are
the most important what would they be do
you think
yeah I mean obviously
um you'd want to know you know
um what the role and response
responsibility looks like what the
structure of the business looks like
what type of person works well in the
business why that person the hiring
manager works there you know everyone's
got a pros and cons list when they're
about to join somewhere you know you can
ask questions like what was on your cons
list what was on your prose list you
know
um you know what what they do
differently to their competition you
know what who are their clients you know
um what stands out to them you know in
the market like what do they who are
their competitors you know where where
they Benchmark themselves and then the
EVP bit for me and for us as a business
is massive you know like we want to know
like you know what you're doing in terms
of training and development what you're
doing in terms of um you know holiday
entitlement parental leave
um working with like you know um charity
partners and whether you you know
whether you support pretend to work
parents in your Workforce whether you
can consider increased flexibility all
of that's really important too
you know some great great things are and
obviously if you do the thing is right
if you get all of that right and
you get all of that information it's
just gonna hugely increase the hopefully
chances of you being successful right
and and helping that business and if
they're not willing to give you that
information or it's very high level and
they're not willing to give you the time
to go through it
it's probably uh a job that you don't
want to be working or a client that you
want to consider saying no to look you
know I have to work this way maybe this
isn't yeah maybe we can't work this way
or like that yeah we need to have that
information right
yeah and yeah I think that's I think
like the whole thing is about being
honest and and you know having that
level of trust and you want to build
those kind of relationships that you can
look back on and go look this is where
we started and this is where we've got
to and I know your business inside out
and we don't often ask the salary
question when we're picking up briefs
either because I suppose when I've been
doing it a while as you know like I can
I can tell a client what the market rate
is for for that role do you know what I
mean and I'd hope people would be able
to get to that stage too as well rather
than having to be dictated by a salary
bracket yeah for sure
so talk to me then about like how like
how have you become how have you got
really good at just being very like
focused diligent with your time like
what what you now do that's that's maybe
a bit different compared to
you know maybe five six years ago or
whatever because I think we spoke about
it right there is a lot of power when
like you're like if you have to get a
certain task done by a certain time
there's just more chance that you're
going to get it done because at a
certain time rather than knowing that oh
I can I can stay later or I'll just stay
a bit later so yeah I'll get it done and
then it can sort of get pushing it can
roll over so how how have you you know
how do you now you know people always
interested in this stuff Charlotte like
how do you now set up your days you know
you're working three and a half days a
week
um how how do you now set up your days
to really ensure maximum output and
efficiency
we want to know the day plan and how you
prioritize things yeah yeah I I guess
for me like I often get into the office
and I feel like I've done a full day at
work anyway but just uh
yeah no I think for me it's like you
know you've got to start your day with
really clear goals and clear objectives
and I think we mentioned this on on the
catch-up like I can't I have my I have a
to-do list every day and I can't not do
what's on my to-do list you know what I
mean I've got a finite amount of time I
need to get it done because I need to
leave at a certain time you know that's
just that's just how I do it and you
know I've got to set boundaries around
my work as well and and you know my
family life it's that's really important
to me so I think you know having those
lists knowing exactly my time frame for
the day is is really vital and then you
know as I say prioritize what you've got
going on in the day and and tick things
off review it at the end of the day and
you have to say yeah just just get it
done
yeah so it's just it's just becoming a
negotiable for you to get yeah things
done absolutely absolutely
has do you think working more on like a
return basis has helped with you being
really efficient and making sure that
the time that you are putting in in
certain areas you know that you know
you're going to get paid for or there's
a much higher chance of you being paid
for
yeah absolutely and I time block a lot
as well so I will time block my day and
so if I've got candidate calls to make
or client calls to make I actually will
diarize that and I'll send my candidates
the invite as well because otherwise you
know you always say oh I'll call you
I'll call you on Tuesday and then gets
the end of the day like oh no I haven't
called that candidate back and I must do
that so I actually make sure I do that
and yes working in retained manner as
well like I do block off my days that
I'm in the office or at home working to
working on my retainer roles as well and
then obviously try and turn off
notifications on anything else that's
going on whether that be slack or my
phone Etc as well and just make sure I
haven't got those kind of um those
disturbances as well
yeah so easy to be distracted and um
I mean I don't turn off my calls from
daycare though like I do
I can't do that I cannot do that no way
yeah I guess look let's just let's just
segue into talking about retainer I
think for a lot of people listen to us
they're always interested to learn and
understand how other recruiters navigate
and approach Business Development how do
they get more out of it what's working
for them
so let's just focus on on this for um a
little bit so correct me if I'm wrong
before creative natives how much like
retained work did you do
barely anything
yeah so let so let's just talk about
that for a second because yeah you know
a lot of people so firstly when I speak
to recruiters that are going on that
Journey oftentimes one of the biggest
barriers can be their mindset because
Sean has got so much evidence of you've
always worked a certain way and you know
you've got the job done you've done it
so by me then saying let's now work with
this way you know that's unnatural for
you to do that and it's like well what
happens if you know I don't feel the job
and these things so what were some of
the initial you know self-limiting
beliefs or the mindset element that you
was maybe coming up against wrestling
with uh before you then got consistently
good at you know selling and selling
this solution so what were some of the
initial barriers yeah I think as you say
just thinking well actually like I've
been working in this way in a contingent
and exclusive manner before and it's
been it's been fine it's been good you
know to a point and then also coming
back to what I said earlier about being
a bit of a people pleaser I was well
what am I going to do if you know
ex-client calls me and then they don't
want to work retained and then I'm
letting them down and I can't feel that
role and then somebody else is going to
get it and this and the other but I
think it's just having you know that
courage and conviction to know that the
the service offering that we're
providing is so much more consultative
and it's going to reap so many rewards
for you know the client the candidate
and yourself that it's just it's just
been a no-brainer for us really
but yeah I mean yeah don't get me wrong
initially I was like oh gosh how's this
going to work well how are my clients
going to feel about this you know yeah
so that would you mind if we just break
this down a bit then because I think
this would be helpful for people so like
how how have you approached you know I'm
sure it's like evolved and you'll
continue to refine it and improve it but
like what does this sales process what
does this process look like in terms of
if you know we are talking about working
with each other on a routine basis
how do we go about doing that in terms
of from firstly from the sales process
has that been any different are you you
know having
um a call uh with me and then we're
deciding if you know what from what I've
learned on this call today I think I
want to talk to you about our retained
solution because I think that's going to
be best suited so let's book in time to
go through what our retained solution
consists of
um and I'm going to put a presentation
together for this Horan project I'm
going to walk you through it et cetera
Etc you can tell me about like what how
what does this sales process look like
and does it look any different to you
know sell this solution
yeah absolutely it does look different
and I think you kind of know on a client
call whether you you want to work the
role retained anyway you know because
um we'll we'll get to the end of the
call and I'll know that I can what I
want to pitch retained for this
particular role and then I would talk to
the client around it you know give them
the understanding and the um it probably
will likely be a candidate client that
I've worked with for a period of time as
well to be honest so it is new you know
that they're not a new client to me but
it's a new way of working with them so
it's all about kind of framing it I
guess to say you know this is how we've
been working
um more recently and it's having just a
magnificent result for our clients and
we've filled every single role in doing
so you know this is this is our module
um it's a you know the way we work is so
much more consultative and we basically
works very very closely with you we
produce an amazing video for you which
goes across all of our socials we've got
a fantastic in-house videographer who
works for creative Natives and she pulls
together a video that's obviously signed
off by the client and then it goes
across the whole team will share that so
it gets millions of views across our
LinkedIn and our socials so that in
itself is a massive draw card for the
client it's part of the process you know
I explained to them that as part of the
process they get so much more visibility
of who we're going to in the market who
we're speaking to will have like a long
list and a short list that we will share
with them and you know of all the
candidates that we've tapped up for the
role and spoken to where they've come
from we have them on a spreadsheet so
it's like who they are their LinkedIn
profile where they're currently working
whether we've engaged with them or heard
back from them and what they've said
about the role and we'll say to the
client you know we'll give you feedback
on your job description we'll tell you
what the clients candidates are saying
about you in the market we have a
regular check-in with you every kind of
seven to ten days so that we go through
um on a video call or a quick phone call
whatever's best for you and we run
through you know where we're at with the
role so we don't just kind of leave you
high and dry we've got regular check-ins
and then we actually as a business have
got these amazing templates that we will
then showcase the top you know five to
however many candidates that would be on
the on the short list to the client in
those calls um which is which is great
and again kind of then go through the
money bit of it saying that it's a
retained model it's not no extra cost to
you it's x amount from the you know
which is then deducted from the final
fee and then we the good thing is we can
we've got um we have an amazing in-house
marketing manager here as well and she's
um generated some amazing kind of flyers
and you know infographics and things
around our retained model and how it
sits compared to the contingent and the
um exclusive model so you can actually
see the differences you know they're
kind of ticked in green and yeah yeah
you know all of that which looks amazing
so again we'd follow up the call with it
all spelled out to the client so
everything's in the body of the email
and then there are the Flyers are like
attached and then it's like yeah
examples of like other videos that we've
done for other clients and how that's
worked
this podcast is proudly partnered with
vincere the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20 000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our mission in helping you get the
most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10 of the usage price forever
use a link in the show notes to get your
hands on that let's get back to the
episode all right cool right let's so
let's just spread this let's say okay
that's that's really really helpful I
was hoping you'd share some of those
things so we've spoken there about
obviously I asked you around the sales
process so it sounds like it sounds like
you're having you know the job briefing
calls that we spoke about earlier and
then depending on what you learn on that
call the client and these things is then
going to determine if this is something
that you're gonna you know pitch for
retained then obviously you then can
segue into look we've been working this
way however this is another way for us
to be working this is our track record
um and these things I guess just quickly
on that
how how did Charlotte navigate that when
you didn't have a track record
you also had a track record in your
industry but you get what I mean like
it's so much easier yeah firstly if
you're listening to this and you're not
using your track record in your
testimonial or case studies to close new
clients you're missing a trick and a lot
of recruiters don't they still very much
just rely on like believe me I can get
this job done for you I'm the best place
person to do it rather than you know
having your success story taught for you
but like how and there's a first initial
approaches
how did you find it when you couldn't
lean on we've got look we've done these
amazing videos for ex clients like you
we've got this success how did you
navigate that just curious
yeah it's a good question
um I think we just we just wanted we we
pop we went out to like clients that we
intentionally had n't quit before and
just said this is our way of working
right and then we we then reap the the
results through that and then you know
so we didn't say yes of course this is
this is our statistics this is what
we're doing and then we moved on to
clients that we did have a very good
relationship with and said this is you
know this is our way of working right
now and let's combine and let's do this
together and I guess the thinking there
is it's just it would have been harder
to go to the existing people because
they've got been used to working a
certain way right exactly the new person
oh this is how creative native works
that's like their perception okay so
just quickly then just to tie this bit
together
you mentioned a few different things
there you mentioned you know I really
like the idea around the sort of video
job spec or the video story around the
employer I really like that I think
that's that's a great
um idea and what a you know a unique
asset to be able to go to the market
with whilst also hopefully giving
potential employees just even more
insight into what it might be like to
work there which can often be really
difficult to truly understand in the
interview processes and these things
right so absolutely love that obviously
you mentioned um you know checking calls
you mentioned like a spreadsheet or
visibility of
um you know what people are doing
so just just to help us out then you're
just talking about their your asset of
this is what our contingent service
looks like this is what our retain
service looks like if me and you decide
to start working with each other because
I have you know free PR director roles
that I wanted to work with me and you
know I always start working on a
retained basis like what so what are the
fundamental core elements of that
process then that makes it more
consultative could you just just so I
understand that so is it okay from this
point every week we're going to get
we're gonna have a check-in call we're
gonna get this this and this would you
mind just breaking that down because I
think that would be really helpful for
people
yeah absolutely so no we diarize like it
will be your call so you'd say yep
Charlotte I'd love to check in on three
o'clock every every Monday morning to
see where you're at with the role so we
diarize that and then I give you a call
every Monday to say okay listen this is
where we're up to the video we we run
like a two-week video Campaign which to
be honest does actually can go further
than that as well so we'll say you know
the video came out last week it's had x
amount of views across the business
we'll bring those stats into it as well
which is really good clients love that
to know how many eyeballs have actually
been on it and then we'll say okay we'll
we'll share our screen we'll run through
like a document with you and say okay
we've reached out to 65 people here they
are you know like um you know and we'll
leave you with that that's your own
document to have as well after the call
and then we'll obviously continue to
keep adding and amending that it's a
Google doc we'll run through who we've
already got on the short list and then
the long list and then depending on when
so so for me in PR it's a little bit
different because if I get a good
candidate I'm more likely to send their
profile over with synopsis straight away
to my client because it moves pretty
fast sure which which I suppose like you
know that that it that that just is how
I have to to work on them but ultimately
what you want to be doing is getting a
short list of you know three to five
people that you then show would showcase
to you and let you know basically in a
visual form as well run through you know
their backgrounds and why they'll be
potentially good for the role and things
like that so it's very visual but it
just is so much more consultative we get
your feedback you get ours we tell you
maybe tweaks that you might need to make
on the JD why people are saying that
they're interested in the role why
they're not what their feedback's been
in market so you just don't get that in
an exclusive or a contingent model
yeah so interesting the visibility piece
isn't it like how powerful that is just
being able to because a lot of those
things let's be honest you might have
been doing those you might be you would
have been doing those things but it was
just internal to you and like you would
know all that information rather than
the client yeah so it is it is
interesting right just by flipping on
his head and just giving them as you
know as much visibility as possible
really showcasing the work that you're
doing you've got those weekly check-ins
they're bought into it you're bought
into it you're advising on look this is
what we keep running into do you think
we should maybe consider tweaking this
changing that
um and then you said there's something
that's really interesting and then like
the this data that you're then you know
curating and collating they then keep is
that right yeah yeah so basically it's
like a live document you know so we'll
we will continue to work it you know and
they will be able to see the amends
being made and we can send or we can
send a new document before each catch up
whatever works best for them it's all
about accountability isn't it really at
the end of the day like you're just that
retained piece just makes everyone so
much more accountable fulfilling that
role and getting it done
I guess part of that sale as well is
like look I'm going to help you you know
get this person that you need but also
in the medium term long term I'm also
helping you build a bit of a talent pool
here or you know you're also going to be
left with like a whole
um you know community of people that
have heard about your business heard
about your story
um that maybe they can tap into in the
future right yeah absolutely so just
curious then
what's ended up being like
how do I say this what's end up being
Your Capacity out of Interest like well
I know it there is but like what what
have you had have you had to learn the
hard way of like how many is too many
retained searches on the go on point
like what's ended up being I know every
Market's different but people might be
interesting okay if I work that way then
how many other jobs could I be working
because that's the nice thing about
contingent I guess is like if I get one
or two free candidates that you know is
the right type of skill set for these
five different companies and these five
different jobs I can get them into all
of those so how have you found that out
of interest in terms of the capacity and
how many jobs you can work this way
yeah it's that's a really good question
because I think that was a little bit
overwhelming at the start as well you
know that is probably a mindset piece as
well so at the moment for example I'm
working I think four or five retained
roles and the rest will be contingent
and exclusive roles to us so yeah and
again for me I work three and a half
days do you know what I mean I have when
it comes to retains you know so yeah I
think that's that's a pretty sweet spot
for me at the moment maybe around that
kind of four to five Mark and then
obviously it is tricky when it sometimes
when it when a client of yours because
our clients do call us now and say how
can we get a video out on LinkedIn like
what are you doing for those guys that
you you know we wanna we want that we
want a piece of that as well and then
being you know having to say well listen
I'm a capacity at the moment but as soon
as that role's filled I'll take you on
as a a retainer but I can also in the
background you know help you look for
somebody too so yeah yeah okay no I love
that so look gone you know really
granular on job briefings retained which
has been pretty fundamental in your um
you know Journey so far I guess let's
talk about something that's absolutely
you know so important to
um in your life which is family like
just I guess why don't we start with the
conversation like just curious like what
what was your experience of
going into work knowing that you're
gonna have to tell your manager that
you're pregnant with your first child
because you know from
from the you know I can only speak to my
partner and get that perspective which I
know like should be scared to do
like she takes her career seriously like
yeah and you know from the things that I
just see online that I consume
I can only imagine how daunting that is
because you might be thinking what's
going to happen am I just gonna be I
don't know forgotten about has all my is
all my hard work just going to be you
know like all the hard work I put into
my career is that just going to go to
grind and start uh stop so I mean why
don't we just start the conversation
there like what what was your mindset
going into like that initial period of
your life because
I assume it can be quite daunting yeah
it can be like it is a funny it's a
funny stage to be in and I I was really
lucky in my old business I was really
well supported with that conversation
you know I think you know I had the
conversation fairly early on and and I
was really well supported as a business
and in that in that role as well on the
PRN Commons desk I had like we I worked
in tandem with an another person on the
desk so for me it wasn't so much a worry
it was probably more a worry that I was
leaving I was so much work you know on
her desk while I was away
um so no it wasn't it was it was
concerning and as much as how am I going
to make this work when I come back do
you know what I mean because ultimately
that's that was more import I wanted to
go off and really enjoy my tend to leave
because you know that that leave can go
so quickly and you know you want to just
be in the right mindset to enjoy it
um but yeah ultimately won that
conversation had had happened I was well
supported through the business and you
know and came back in a part-time
capacity then as well actually so I
think I worked four days then so how
long how long did you have off
just I
uh
okay so so what was this strategy coming
back then like when you were starting to
come back so because a year is is a long
time to be away from like recruitment
your recruitment desk or these things a
lot can change right so I understand why
that may be thinking more about that
how's it going to work when I get back
this is going to be you know I have a no
now another human being to be taken care
of well I don't just have my career and
myself and my partner to think about so
talk to us a bit about yeah so what was
the approach coming back then you
mentioned there part-time but what what
did what did um a normal working week
look like when Charlotte had a firstborn
then new return
yeah it was pretty hectic to begin with
I remember I used to have to walk I had
to walk miles to daycare because we
didn't have two cars at the time we're
getting to work a bit yeah getting to
work a bit flustered and then obviously
like my hours were a little bit reduced
as well so I'd work I think 9 30 till
about 4 4 30 and then do pick up as well
I mean I was super fit but um because of
all the walking but um but yeah no I I
tried again just just try and set
boundaries you know like as we said like
my home life's really important to me so
I knew I wanted to come back in a
part-time capacity but also then not
take too much away from this market and
the the base that I built up for myself
you know it's something that I'm really
proud of and I wanted to come back and
give it my all because there's
ultimately other people now relying on
me as well so fortunately I was in a
good position because my colleague had
been keeping things ticking over for me
so I guess it was all about that
re-engagement piece with my clients and
my candidates so coming back in reaching
back out to them getting meetings you
know it's actually quite a nice soft in
because you yeah you know you've got
that story to tell and you can pick up a
phone and you know and speak to somebody
after a year and it's they they want to
hear from you because they want to hear
how you've been doing so it was actually
quite a nice end so yeah that's that's
kind of how I started off flustered and
making phone calls what was what was
most challenging about that first time
that maybe you least expected do you
think um I I think probably the feeling
of the vulnerability like I didn't you
know that whole imposter syndrome like
coming back after being a mum and just
solely focusing on that for for a year
basically like what am I going to talk
about you know like what have I
forgotten everything like you know what
I mean I don't even know how to use the
laptop like I can't even remember you
know if I've had a coffee that morning
that kind of stuff I think really hit me
quite hard and then also like just you
know I I really missed my little one
terribly as well it was it was it was
hard like it is a it is a big adjustment
I can you know you're constantly
checking your phone to check that
they're getting on all right at daycare
you know you're basically like leaving
your most prized possession in with
somebody that you know you don't really
know too well at that point you know so
it's a lot you've you're dealing with a
lot of emotions and you know all of
that's running through your head and
then you're trying to focus on on your
work at the same time and being
something to your work colleagues and
your clients and candidates but then
also like your heart is elsewhere so
that was tricky
did you feel guilty
yeah of course it's your mum guilt as
the worst
what does that feel what do you feel
guilt really what what are you feeling
guilty for oh just that I wasn't with
her you know and I wanted to be with her
and you know ultimately I know why I'm
working and I really enjoy work and
people would say to me oh but you know
you get to have a coffee in peace and
you get to like you know not have a
nappy bag on your back and all that
stuff and I was like well that's
something I really liked I like all that
you know so it's it's just having it's
just you know it takes a while to find
that balance and it's something that I'm
really passionate about like you can see
it in return to what appearance you can
see it in their faces when they're
coming into an office and their heads
elsewhere their heart is elsewhere like
it's it's a very vulnerable time so yeah
it yeah it needs to be acknowledged and
supported and I was lucky enough I was
in a in an office and in a company that
really did support that but it is a very
tricky time to navigate
yeah like uh just be curious to
understand how you think
recruitment companies can you know
intentionally create an environment
where it does make people returning
parents feel like the way that you felt
like because that you know that's that's
amazing that you've felt that way but a
lot of people like aren't
um no don't end up feeling that way
right either you know from some of the
conversations that I've had it could be
leading up to you know letting them know
that you want to go to maternity and
you've got your first child on the way
like and to then I don't know almost
feel like okay well
she's done then like probably not going
to come back or be as successful as she
was now so like straight away you know
if things are being made difficult for
them and then likewise when they're
coming back like I think ages ago I
did a whole week on women in Recruitment
and there was some real you know horror
stories for women who were returning to
work and they had their contract book
just given to someone else and like
that so you know how do you think people
can be um you know better at making
there's anything that you found because
I'm sure you advise this too you know in
your world
um particularly if a lot of the
recruitment companies are being run by
men where you know we're we some cannot
be aware of like what could help people
you know what I mean because we're not
gonna truly go through that and really
maybe truly experience the things that
you feel or it would be different so is
there anything that you found yourself
consistently advising people on to make
that environment hopefully then
conducive with you know having return
them
um parents say you know what actually
they were really great and they're
supportive
yeah yeah there's a number of things
actually like you hear quite often about
businesses who when somebody's on
maternity leave they'll have like
keeping in touch days so they're like
you know I think Nicole kid days in the
UK certainly that you know it you can
take them or leave them I actually
probably think I probably wouldn't have
wanted them like you know I was quite
happy to just have my head down and be
in a mum I love it but you know for
those big kind of like days or off sites
or like you know big kind of team
announcements and things like that you
know the employee the parent is asked to
come in if they'd like to and they're
paid for those keeping in touch days
like things like that's a really great
initiative to offer just to at least
offer somebody that's you know on
maternity leave to just prove that they
haven't been forgotten about like
they're still important to the business
like I think that's imperative as well
and then also you know like just you
know we have I had orientation with my
little girl going into daycare it's
almost like you you kind of need that
coming back to the workforce as well you
know like is is this Stark reality when
you walk in that door and you're like oh
my God will be here for like you know
seven eight hours or whatever it is so I
think orientation day is like easing
yourself back in I know Ryan because
I've come back when I joined creative
notices I was off the back of my second
maternity leave and Ryan had said to me
my director here like you know come back
in one day a week if that's easier for
you like use yourself back in it doesn't
need to be like all straight in for you
know your whole kind of weekly loads I
think that's really important and then
also just having like a like a setup and
I know this isn't always going to like
work for some companies but like for
example here in our office we've got
like a baby changing room and somewhere
you can go on a spread Express if you're
still breastfeeding and like storage for
for milk and things like that that's
really important it just makes you feel
like you're actually acknowledged like I
you know I came back and I still
breastfeeding that stuff's really
important that was really important to
me
um and then also just yeah the things
that guys wouldn't think about
that's just the dream no of course not
and I was terrified I was terrified
someone was just gonna like use my
breast milk in their cup of coffee
imagine imagine
yeah
crazy story around like yeah oh can you
make me a tea and it's like yeah I'll
use this milk I was hoping
those types of things right yeah yeah
they're really good initiatives and then
also just like you know having
colleagues that understand you know
whether they're like parents themselves
and they can see it in your face when
you might need to take a break or have a
walk around the block and then equally
you know colleagues that maybe don't
have children or don't have a family
just to be like do you know what I'm you
know I'm gonna take that person out for
a coffee or for a wine or something like
that just to kind of like have a general
chat with them because you know you just
don't know to you know you know what
what a daily struggle is like for
somebody just coming straight back into
your business after having a baby
so yeah as you said you you went through
uh you know you then brought another
human being into the world family of
four
what do you do maybe different like is
there anything that maybe you approach
people differently because
you know I mean when I have you know
when we have children hopefully like the
first time you're gonna be like what the
is going on like I have no clue
what we're doing and then I feel like
the second time you may not feel like an
expert be like right there's some this
is Common Ground we've been here before
so like the second time around was there
anything you did differently that you've
you know found maybe help that you
didn't think of the first time whether
that be you know leading up to going on
to maternity leave whether it be
returning back
yeah yeah I think well obviously I would
turn like leading up to them my
maternity leave I actually was like
right bang in the middle of like just
when covert had happened so for me I was
working from home anyway and I obviously
then realized that flexibility wise I
could actually achieve quite a lot so
for me coming back into a role I knew
that I probably needed more flexibility
for my family like I think I was doing
three days a week in the office and one
from home when I first went back after
my first child and then now I do like
one and a half days at home two in the
office but it's very flexible I could do
less than that if I wanted and I you
know I guess coming back I was probably
a lot kinder to myself and and you know
you know and and recognize those signs
when I was starting to feel concerned or
anxious and needed to kind of like you
know check in and check that the
children were okay and you know or give
myself like a bit of a break if I was
like feeling like I was anxious or
rushing to one appointment to another
you know it's just I think it's a
mindset thing as well and just feeling
support in that mindset which I
ultimately do here
and how
like how would you compare
Charlotte and the energy that you put
into your career and how your approach
work compared to then
Charlotte who's also a mum but is also
you know building and growing her career
like what would you say are the main
differences
yeah I think well my priority like I'm
the priorities of complete completely
changed do you know as I said to you
before I'm doing it for my family now so
it's it's almost made me up my game you
know and I was never I was never not
competitive with myself in the first
place but I think you know that's
probably made me even more so
um but I and again from like a
boundaries point of view you know I am I
am very strict of my boundaries I think
we talked about you know I don't work on
Fridays but I you know I will check my
emails and and things like that
occasionally but the Charlotte of old
would have just you know worked worked
till late you know checked her emails
been up at the Cracker door and checking
them as well not being very present
whereas I'm fine that I have to be very
present and present in my work life and
I'm present when I'm at home with the
family too
then I guess just final thing then how
did you have like a community of other
women that had been on a similar Journey
was that helpful have you sort of then
ended up finding that building that for
yourself how important is that
yeah no it is and and I have friends
obviously outside of work that were on
my kind of like parental leave Journey
with me and then I've also got a couple
of really good friends within creative
natives that are you know Loyals who I
work with here is them return to it
parent in fact our children in very
similar ages so we lean on each other
tremendously you know we get into the
office in the morning and have the have
the kind of mum chat which poor Holly
has to deal with but um but then we get
that out of the way you know and we can
constantly keep checking in with each
other through the day and things like
that it's really important to have that
Community like you know I don't I'm from
the UK but I don't have we don't have
our family here so for for me finding
that Community whether that be external
or internal to work is really important
well uh surely uh Charlie Charlotte
thank you only my dad calls me too early
sorry
um look honestly thank you so much
sharing with that I know that'd be
helpful for so many people like why I
always try and encourage people like
yourself to come on the podcast is
because there'll be a lot of people
listening to is that don't have role
models and people to point to in their
business to say oh I can build a
successful recruitment career whilst
also building a family which is really
important to me I think the more people
you know who can you know point at that
and have more evidence to go I know that
is possible
um the better I feel or at least
hopefully it might make people feel less
anxious about it and less worried about
it
um because you know I don't think it's
very it must be really tough to feel
like because I have these conversations
with my partner where it's like it's
like career or like family or it's like
when I do then choose the fan like when
I'm building a family it's like yeah
careers over for like however many years
um so yeah I want to say yeah kudos to
you thank you so much for you know
sharing your journeys of that as well as
you know the wisdom on you know the
retained and and how you've you know
continue to get better as a recruiter
but thank you so much for joining me on
the pod
you're welcome thanks so much for having
me